cette résidence de 8,6 millions de
dollars cette maison ne vaut pas 8
millions et tu seras ailleurs que par un
bus si le conducteur fait ce pour quoi
il est payé
il y à un million de raisons de ne pas
aimer oren letter toucher à ma voiture
et je vous fais qu'à stériliser mais bon
c'est en couple hiller les cheveux
est-ce qu'il vaut vraiment la peine de
dire quoi que ce soit demander à tout le
monde alors que plainte à la
gestionnaire est déjà fait ne vous at
elle pas mentionné que cet immeuble
m'appartient je viens d'avoir j'ai vendu
des maisons plus vieille que vous ayez
été en plein pires conditions ça fait
plaisir à entendre qu'ils sachent quoi
francs j'ai fait une gaffe je voudrais
la vie d'une femme et justine que tu es
ce qui suit à part mon chat au dossier
comme un paréo faim et un véritable road
non non tu es vraiment incroyable bingo
aujourd'hui je voudrais tu t'occupes de
ma fille pendant mon absence qu'est ce
qu'il y avait mon office mais qu'ils
soient bien que c'est ma petite fille
sur mywa thématiques
il a déjà couché avec la bonne je veux
venir faire les sandwichs on a tout ce
qu'il faut pour devenir une épouse
exemplaire
une comédie love cette boîte posa sur la
boîte gay sur la boîte qui joue sa
collection sur l'amitié
je suis ta seule amie mon cher aurel
croit avoir trouvé quelqu'un d'autre qui
m'aiment bien alors tu peux mourir
famille quelle est ta couleur préférée
pour ta chambre non non c'est pas une
bonne idée ça se fera jamais ça toutes
les raisons qui nous rassemble
dernière fois que j'ai baisé je me suis
déboîté le jeu serait ce par hasard une
tentative de me faire la cour vu sous
cet angle là mike adams diane keaton
mieux même
madame il est interdit de fumer troubles
vous êtes trop jeune pour fumer
mais voilà
mais j'aimais mon bébé
bonsoir voilà ce qui arrive après une
relation sexuelle